[Music] citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for what if Episode 7 a surprisingly great
season of Television joined once again by Koy
jandro who I gave five real reject shirts to
and he decided to wear none of them today I was
wondering would this come up in the first inro
or the second were you wondering you know what
happened I hung them all up cuz I liked them cuz
I wanted them to like get really nice yeah but
then I GL they're in the closet you know what
it's Christmas week Christmas week what do you
think of this episode is it good we don't know
what it is we're about to find out in real time
so you know what to do leave a like um also be
sure to subscribe click the notification get
notified when our reaction for seven no eight
is up on the yeah eight is up on the channel
and thank you to prepper for being awesome and
helping us Ed down these highlights and thank
you to everyone specifically you who has joined
us at our patreon page becomeing super sexy
rejects over there you get the full inter and
watch along reing up with your own copy of
what if and John and I cover several things
over there exclusively with highlights and watch
Longs included let's get to it people let's do
it in a campaign of Fire and Blood King Odin
sought to unite the nine Realms under the Throne
of Asgard still can't get over how good this
looks it's so much better okay get over I can't
even place what differences but it's gorgeous
his executioner and firstborn daughter Hela oh
we're going to get a Hela episode nice one by
one the branches of the world's tree fell under
their control they should have kept hell around
is it capelan Chet that would be nice the entire
Cosmos is out there waiting to be ruled you wish
to stop at nine rounds there comes a point in time
my dear when a warrior must lay down his sword
that's definitely Anthony Hopkins yeah unist who
else can sound like that unable to quench his
daughter's thirst for blood and imprisoned her
in hell oh it's cool we're actually just seeing
what happened in this universe hel's insolence
inspired another idea you see father without a
fight I'm no one woo oh reversal of Fortune no
God should have dominion over death who has so
little appreciation for life well ridden I now
take from you your power oh interesting reversal
yeah Thor one with Hela Thor one and Ragnarok yeah
oh is hel banished to Earth no no
I cast you out whosoever wears this
Crown should she know Mercy shall possess
the power of Hela oh definitely Hopkins oh
yeah this doesn't look like New
Mexico Oh is she going to the 10
Rings is this going to be what is
this the place called come come
on remember the name chongi land
Chicago or we just saw an Asian guy
in New Mexico yeah he just lives there
no oh there this when we get the the 10 rings
that fueled his power Shu and woo knew all too
well the most powerful forces on Earth often
come from Beyond Amen to that brother that's
an interesting concept Hela wiwoo the
weird benefit that we have of of being
fortunate enough to watch this in advance is not
knowing what every not knowing the title of the
episodes yeah it's really fun to have like it
feels like roulette we're like let's see what
today is O idra Saba's back I feel like they
underused idba the whole time they had him I'm
shocked he comes back cuz he's so great hey
man he needs the money cuz he was underused
that's true idra is hurting you know he's not
out there yeah him and jimon Hanson never get
underused black actors the miracle of nature
that brings the sky down to earth so poetic
but when woo was about to discover someone far
more intriguing had fallen from the heavens I
love how that helmet felt perfect yeah that's
where it goes cool oh man Hips Don't Lie midgard
wonderful oh she speaks Mandarin I'm
afraid the only one who gives orders
around these parts is me I do appreciate
a man who's brave enough to attempt uh
jewelry but you see darling I'm
not most people I'm the goddess
of death oh she can't do the thing
she can't do it just no powers take
her oh dear here we go hella oh no
oh that's really funny mortal PL o
revolting I'm just a helpless [Music]
woman oh she's still SK she can still
fight she has the skill yeah it would
be hard to learn how to fight in real
time without getting injured though oh
like even punching would hurt for her he
[Music] attracted that power it is not of this
realm nor are you I was not expecting shanok
if I only had my crown it would be you who would
kneel before me then show me what a fascinating
Dynamic I can't de if you're brave or stupid done
your crown and we shall find out he just wants to
challenge it's really lodged in there
isn't it how does Gra work here on me
you know what doesn't matter how does gravity
work father please don't do
this to me I'm embarrassed
[Music] father it's also fun mirroring at
the rain and everything in the first Thor
yeah but setting it here with W wo watching
over just give it's a completely different
Dynamic that I am very much appealed to because
he would be drawn to someone like her immediately
what is this an invitation I like white girls
if you would join me for dinner I also like a
young wio getting some time to shine I guess
I've been subjected to worse forms of torture
color's not bad at least your blood won't stain
it when I slit your throat he's so attracted are
they going to fall in love Brides even wear
it on their wedding day wedding day I didn't
realize you meant to make my imprisonment a
life sentence I see in you a fighter hella my
father once saw the same that fight he nurtured
it exploited it and then as soon as my ambition
outgrew his own he called me a monster when woo
can do the same yep familiar Story the 10 Rings
were a gift bestowed upon me a gift I give back
to the world in return by taking command of its
people our world is plagued by dangerous forces is
that what you take me for just another dangerous
Force oh man your father may have feared
the fight in you but I do not fight with
me hel and together we can protect the world
protect the world interest well that's how
he perceives it I just know what I want and
what is it is she just playing him yeah yeah
I don't know she might actually end up falling
for him too sweet dream I want her [Laughter]
alive it's back to feeling like the animatrix
yeah I was going to say it's pretty especially
the color composition very animatrix I love
when these episodes have been embracing
genre oh that's right he's back well you
saying you know a way to get out of here
oh I'm sorry is that your sorry I was under the
impression I was talking to your [Music] face I
think the characterization is so well drawn
no pun intended I guess you're not the first
ass I've ever followed into battle Yeah we
didn't get a lot of her but I did feel like
she established who she was pretty quickly
and I wanted more so it's nice but at this
Joy Ride of yours doesn't bear fruit it
will be your ass for your face what a
great way to justify gway with the word
ass Disney rebellious heading towards
[Music] Deadpool I bu to buide the thousand
years of war to die at the hands of foliage
this clever there's like a she's like
Kathleen Turner like that kind of that
Middle Middle Atlantic accent p forward I'm
sorry you want me to tr you after you've led
me into the enchanted murder Forest
her being just offut by being mortal
is great like a swashbuckling Leading
Lady quality to her did you hear [Music]
that show yourself I command
[Laughter] you o oh my gosh oh cool
hello she is falling from my view why didn't
Marvel promote this at all this is so well done
like one of their best pH I don't understand this
is so well done with a crazy cast our realm is a
border protecting the people of Earth from threats
of the underworld why mean no harm my quarrels
with a man named wwo technically with my father
say it was both of them also my dad has this new
girlfriend friger she's dreadful woman not really
a fan of hers either so yeah it's just those
three one cannot fend off Darkness with more
Darkness only light yes it's a lovely sentiment
to be sure the meme stripping her away from
her powers really gets you to know her and I
am the goddess of death and what better way
to secure your mission than by recruiting me
to your cause the whole fending off Darkness
with with like things the manipulation being
so on Our Sleeve is great cannot be serious fear
not we have methods to ensure she won't betray
us it's all coming back into play I really
don't know how this is going to end I don't
either and I love the blending of magic our
new magic and our magic we've known 10 rings
that could even destroy a God if such power
indeed exists on midgard there's no telling
what its people could be capable of and our
age of Peace might be shortlived oh this is
so compelling they're they've really achieved
making these shorts stories feel like oh this
could be a great feature they all feel like
movies yeah they're cinematic and we can expect
to get to the fighting when but our practice
requires a cultivation of your inner World a
Unity of technique and spirit oh good what fun
what about those fire knives just breathe hel
it's like those classic M movies I grew up on
where white person stumbles into white Foreigner
stumbles into like Asian and learn yeah this was
a common Trope four years infinite possibility in
the blankest of canvases Focus Unity peace why
do you seek to master our practice to overthrow
wed for what so I can take his 10 rings for
myself and use them to seek Vengeance on
my father or what but why and when all the
Realms across the cosmos have finally been
conquered
cool it's like hypnosis
enough oh my God sweet young
Hela in her child work father
why did you chain him he is born
with the heart of a fighter the
king must tame his threats to ensure
that they fight is that fenis yeah
yeah wow we really humanizing her freedom freedom
from control the freedom to choose my own path
that's what that's what it all really comes
down to now you're ready to begin what's cool
is that even though the plot isn't Canon Tor
main timeline the humanization of her would
still be consistent this will still enhance Hela
if we see her again yeah that's what liked about
the Iron Man story is it didn't take away from
the loss but we enhanced him the breath in your
lungs when your mind is at peace you can see the
lesson oh this is awesome not
bad you still have a lot to
learn please turn Hela into a white savior the
goddess of death white savior to live the lessons
then you become a master [Music] well hell has
become a martial arts master that's so cool but
is she worthy if you choose this path you will
walk it alone no my father chose a path for me
long ago and if I ever wish to be free to choose
my own and I must face him with or without you
it's cool because when Shan Chi came to this
part of the land he had a training montage
or whatever but I actually feel like there's true
development for Hela here yeah like Shan was kind
of rushed is ironic considering the desperate
run times yeah pull back pull back behind the
Gates wow these two Magics fighting each other
impressive armor make some Dragon SC and VI
with the strength to combat threats of Untold
mystical power personally I missed the dress
though these two teaming up who would
have coming in as the villain oh the
body's desending in the backg end slow
motion embrace me daughter I have come far to
avenge your name Avengers embrace me daughter
return to my side hel and we shall bring
midgard under our protection truly no I
will no longer be party to your Conquest
perhaps you have forgotten I stripped you
of your crown without it you are nothing oh I
love the we get to see the villainous side of
Odin yeah we need to separate him from G who's
G that is oh he even going to see his weapon in
action I love that the dragon armor is
useful in this exact capacity it's great
well talk about wish fulfillment Darkness
cannot fend off Darkness only light can
the T Rings look so
[Music] cool I knew I should have locked
you away but I had the chance just amazing
choreography and camera work I wonder if it
was MOA especially the martial artist yeah
you show the martial art skills oh grab
it so much happening oh damn cool [Music]
sacrifice yourself wo fire [Music] KN the
prophecy everything she wanted fire dager
ass oh sweet
cool
[Music] ten ring punch it plays like
when you're fighting Odin in a video
game and then it ends with a cut scene on
the final 100% yeah like they just cut to
that for us let us end this violence once and
for all oh that's how she's Worthy is [Music]
forgiveness Odin you son of a [__]
my daughter pass and a chance to end
her life just like you said no God
should have dominion over death
who has so little appreciation
for life she never forgot the
words oh and then Odin's own doing just
like it always is but learning the lesson
literally at the hands of Odin oh my God
and reag yeah I was thinking it should
come back as a different color yeah
she's hell of the white yeah [Music]
pure Majestic God look at the lines the throne
is yours if that is indeed what you seek only
from there can I unmake your Empire the nine
Realms will know freedom and the cosmos soon
thereafter she has the Loki AR basically in 30
minutes on an ancient Battlefield a man and a
woman a moral and a goddess the 10 rings and the
armies of Asgard forged an alliance both Loki and
her just need to realize why they are the way
they are and they'll realize they're actually
all right people little inner child work changes a
lot an Empire not of conquerors but of liberators
liberators cool campaign Across the Universe
which forever prove even the darkest of Hearts
can come to no peace wow that's amazing that
last shot doing the slow-mo and also Gathering
the energy of that Ragnarok like slow-mo that was
so cool I just I love how they really do ask I I
really get this sense that this time around
the writers thought to themselves truly the
question of what if what would happen if Hela
interacted with Wen wo in this time period and
went through this experience and then they from
a psychological standpoint and let that dictate
how the plot would unfold and who is Odin at
this point in time who's W wo at this point
in time how do we want Hela to end like where
do we want Hela to find herself also like what
movies didn't get the time to flash out certain
characters because I've always felt like Ragnarok
didn't give hella her do so it feels like they
were like what can we do to blend these things
and I'll also say [__] the the outfit that
she was wearing was so gorgeous I feel like a
change clothes if Ki had taken the clothes out
of his closet the clothes available at reation
shop.com I could Ascend where you get clothes
like this RR shirt to represent yourself as a
citizen of the reject Nation or our awesome child
protection services shirt with Joel from The Last
of Us carrying baby grou or space babies space
babies of the Galaxy or any of our Ahsoka shirts
or a recently launched Doctor Who shirt one
of our top sellers this year the one of the
best ways my personal favorite way to support the
John because we are creatively involved with them
ourselves people so please go ahead get yourself
a shirt say segue it's a natural segue natural seg
my delivery remains sincere that's the key yeah
that's that's his Arc yeah my AR to sincerity
just just boom look at him he found his sincere
pitch yes yes both vocally and in delivery is a
pun uh I do find myself Eng engaging into the
point where I'm like oh yes we are doing a rea
we' just be silent because I find just to be
silent and absorb so want to appreciate which
to me is the mark of breath work yeah it's the
mark of any good um any any good thing that we
are actually reacting to is when you're like
oh yeah it's that engaging um so yeah please
koi thoughts speak it into the Universe I love a
good uh wax on wax off Walkabout story I'm a big
I'm a sucker for finding your inner peace uh I'm
a sucker for therapy and they definitely had a lot
of therapeutic elements especially the inner child
work being the most obvious but I really love when
a character that you like becomes a character
you love and I have always felt like Hela was
underappreciated in the in the pantheon of of
the Rushmore villains people always talk about
they always talk about uh you know kilmonger and
Thanos and you know I've always had Hela in my uh
top five Marvel villains but she only had one
movie and I didn't feel like they ever got to
really establish more or a way she could come back
and this was the last thing I expected but to give
her that Loki Arc to give both Odin his journey
of darkness which we've hinted at but not really
gone down and then to have winw get time in his
period all of this as a mashup of everyone getting
to play is what what if Comics do really well and
you mix that with this animation making it feel
like it's accurate to a time that we didn't get
to experience as much of uh this was so beautiful
this was really a great episode that really plays
with narrative in a fun way where you mentioned
these character growth arcs she she did she she
literally she became White she got whiter she she
couldn't be she was so white she hell a white got
white past H white got whiter and then saved uh
but she uncolonized but I I do feel like uh when
you have these narratives that you had mentioned
where you go back to the character in their normal
continuity this will affect my experience of Hela
which is really exciting I like when things like
a what if comic can make me go oh that is a a a
direction of the character I hadn't thought of
but it does affect my mainstream continuity so
this was uh one of those episodes where I I really
wish Marvel had doubled down on how good this was
cuz I didn't think that was Kate Blanchett if you
told me Kate Blanchett came back to Hela as one of
the reasons to watch what if I would have been way
more excited yeah well she has the the personality
and the Cadence in this episode of those charact
like it's a it's a genre blend of a couple of of
course can't think of any specific movies right
now I mean you were like saying Karate Kid and
like but there's also those those other kind of
fantasy movies where like guy from modern day
is thrusted into period piece time you know like
espcially the 8S yeah those kind of like comedies
family comedies or something there's like a
lot of those kinds of films it's a little bit
of a blend of that with with a bit of like that
romanting the stone aspect to it so she has this
hodg podge of personalities and and I I loved
I I I I'm I'm right there with you I Echo all
the same sentiments that you had of um falling in
love with her character even more so and then even
getting a chance to see wwu's romantic side which
was teased in it but it it was teasing shangqi but
you get more of his heartbroken melancholic side
and here you get to see him when he's like at the
prime of his Conquest days yeah falling in love
and uh where he's such a charmer then and also
getting to see Odin at his villainous time where
he's also in the conquest at the time and and the
mash this feels like the genuine wish fulfillment
of what would happen like that improv game of like
what would happen if this happened you watch
it come to life in a way where you're like oh
I crave seeing versions of these guys come into
live action reality like like last season was just
strange Supreme I just want to see that guy and
then this is many this has been delivering on so
many and then this one to give that um that that
Asian genre and martial arts blend and but also
with those other kind of swashbuckling films that
we sort of grew up on all mustered into one with
honoring the Fantastical mythological elements
and giving us great action on top of that with
a wonderful Arc that does feel reflective of
Loki you know realiz your childhood trauma you
know you set realize what you actually want not
fulfilling your father's goals of you yeah it's
very it's very much a Loki AR and now you're the
benevolent leader in all this and and then once
again Thanos about to get his ass kicked always
he's right there waiting he's the punching bag you
know those guys are a punk Thanos is the punching
bag of the wh ifs I also think that this is one of
those really cool things where in comics you
have those variant toys like when you've got
a different action figure because it's dressed
different like I immediately thought like man
a hell of the white toy be awesome this is doing
that comic book thing where you've got variations
on characters that isn't just a variant in the
modern context of like it's a different Universe
this feels completely like a new character while
being true to the character and they're nailing it
man this season's great the last thing I expected
to do at the end of this year koi was be here with
you and say what if season 2 is genuinely better
than most comic book things that came out this
year wow you're right I mean all the DC ones for
sure peacemakers this year last year Peacemaker
was okay I'm just I'm just gonna say Peacemaker
is my favorite DC show I'm just making sure I'm
being fair but this is up there with like gen
V for me and um invincible so far uh Loki is
my favorite but this it's hard for me to quantify
Invincible season 2 cuz it's so short it's notet
so not complete yeah it really is cuz I I really
loved a couple episodes but there's only four so
it's like but I do agree this is one of the best
comic book adaptations of the year and I would
never after what if season one thought I'd be uh
it's better than Quantum Mania secret invasion of
Marvels by a lot yeah it's like the only like out
out of the for me Loki is the best thing there's
Guardians 3 which is great you but like across
the spiderverse Loki and this are my top three
comfy I would say this is part of the Great Camp
of combook things this year yeah and not part of
the Bad Camp not part of the mid or bad and so
it D had four movies this year I know and it
blows my mind that this movie that this show is I
thought with this lackluster promotion they were
I was like I thought they were burying It Disney
Disney knows they got another stinker on their
hand instead I'm like guys what do you do this is
the one you should have had your yeah this is so
the premere had the creators which was cool but
it didn't have like anyone from the cast that I
heard know what the hell is the S strikes over
yeah and these cast is huge like anyone what's
going on there was nothing at the LC cap like this
is such a big event it's insane how good this is
I don't know man it's a disappointment it's a
disappointment of what is going on with the lack
of press my question is what if they promoted it
yeah see that movie cuz this should be everywhere
there should be a bigger conversation I the last
thing I expected us to be here would you being
like I'm looking forward to watching the next
episode yeah yeah so yesterday in our real time
uh we filmed a bunch and then we today like our
texting was totally different of like okay wait
we're actually going as opposed to like well on
we got to film like this was a different Dynamic
Al together yeah no I'm here going there's only
two left I got to remember to like express my
thoughts yeah yeah this one had me mesmerized this
one and it also had that meditative nature where
was like very tranquil and like the the the that
world always makes me like calm and quiet and it
worked cuz it was so immersive and plus I love
a good white savior I mean look at me come on
obviously it's what we do I watched the help
recently not for this channel no just on your
own yeah I did actually you don't watch a lot of
movies on your own you watch the help that was
the one I did on my own how often do you watch
a movie you're like I'm going to watch the help
this is the move well I watched it because other
people were going to react to it yeah I needed a
work okay so it's still for work let's not let's
not pret I was gonna say if you casually watch
the help of all the time you sp I still thought
it was touching and boys it a white savior film
and the the caucacity of those people they're not
just white they glow I I I loved it like man this
is what we need more of loveed it and I know Viola
Davis disowns it or something I don't know she
rejects it says one of the bad career decisions
she's made or some [__] like that I she like
straight up say something like I shouldn't have
made that movie oh wow but I loved it and she's
great she's always great she's great in the movie
yeah yeah this this movie needed the pr of the
help God so guys what is your favorite white
savior leave it in the comments below I think
Midwestern Jesus for me you know how how everybody
paints him like you and McGregor even though he's
brought in the Le too broad I was thinking like a
cinematic with like like Tom Cruz and Last Samurai
that's a hell of a white savior Matthew MCC in
that Slavery movie he did 12 Years of Slave he
wasn't in that was he no no the one that was
true yeah you know those guys that you mix
up Brad Pit was in 12 years slave yeah he was
produced it true help save he did yeah Brad Pit
was a white savior of that while producing it to
show how good he is and making movies that help
people I mean in all fairness in that time they
would have got that guy out of that situation
is a white guy and at that time the only thing
that would have got in that movie made is Brad
Pit money look at him go white savior in twice Neo
he's like half asian is Neo white savior he's half
white half asian he's does that count as white
he literally is a Jesus like parallel like he's
I thought white savior mainly qualifies as like
white person enters a specific kind of culture
or ethnicity look all people save them from most
people or troubling the oppressed people of Zion
that mostly aren't White that's true black man
calls on you Morpheus is like hey we need you
to learn Kung Fu and appropriate this culture
the other black people on my Council are not a
big fan of you or really just one guy there's
other white people there's one white bad guy
one white good guy there's guy with the eyebrows
yeah but cyer bad guy and then then uh you know
Neo learns guess is a wi saavor I guess so
a little bit it's a stretch it's a stretch
I can't think of any right now which is ironic
cuz that's like the biggest Tri true and it's
made by you know trans director so it gets a pass
sure sure sure sure sure but fight club's written
by a gay man so does that allow you know I don't
know if Republicans when they say snow fake they
understand who they're quoting I've always found
that funny like when they call people snowflakes
I'm like you know that's a a gay man trying to
come to terms with being gay and you're out there
espousing his film as this hyper masculine like
do you know what you're saying they don't all
right well I think we made our Point did we do
we have one that's the question what if Greg coy